But, I can recall a very special moment for me, which I keep in my memory.
When I was playing in this Olympiad, game 10,...
...I was concentrated very much on the board and after calculating some lines,...
...I looked up from the chessboard and who did I see?
The world champion Gary Kasparov watching my game.
Wow.
The player who I admired and I respected so much and I learned so much from his games.
It gave me inspiration and gave me energy, too.
I smashed my opponent in that game within a few moves.
After the Olympiad, a journalist asked Kasparov what does he think about my chess.
Do you think that it's possible that one day, Judit will challenge you?
He would say,...
..."I'm absolutely sure that she's going to become the woman's world chess champion."
"But, if we will play?"
And then he continued, "But I'm convinced that it's almost impossible."
Almost.